[Music]
I welcome to this special edition of
Hannity act to the deep states day of
reckoning now tonight we are now inching
closer and closer to real truth real
justice and holding those who abuse
power at the highest levels accountable
for over two years on this program we've
watched a political witch-hunt like
we've never seen in American politics
before based on lies and smears and
outright conspiracy theories and just
like we've been telling you all week the
Russia hoax has now completely unraveled
Muller report is over it is dead it is
buried we have now had four separate
investigations oh the FBI 9-month of
vestigation house Intel committee
bipartisan Senate committee and even the
Muller report no collusion no conspiracy
with Russia and as we predicted it is
now boomeranging right on to those who
did abuse power did try to influence the
outcome of an election and then overturn
a duly elected president Act one is over
the curtain is beginning to rise act 2
begins there is a new sheriff in town
and his name is Bill Barr and earlier
today he weighed in on the origins of
the Russia probe take a look at this
like many other people who are familiar
with intelligence activities I had a lot
of questions about what was going on I
assumed I think I get answers when I
went in and I have not gotten the
answers that are in oil satisfactory and
and in fact have probably more questions
and that some of the facts that
I've learned don't hang together with
the official explanations of what
happened what do you mean by that that's
that's all I really will say things are
just not jiving things are not jiving on
this show now we have been honest from
the start and in the process over two
years we have been digging deep we've
uncovered yes the biggest abuse of power
corruption scandal in modern political
history maybe in all of our history so
tonight for you we have a special show
we have brought in together the all-star
ensemble cast those that have every step
of the way been helping America get to
the truth and exposing the spying
scandal this Russia conspiracy theory
since the start so tonight for the full
hour we're gonna break it all down we're
gonna do what we do night after night
we're gonna stick to the facts and the
truth we're gonna be honest and when
everyone else the 99% of liars O's that
push hoaxes and it conspiracy theories
the media mob as they continue to be
wrong a rigged investigation into
Hillary Clinton to save their favorite
candidate the dirty Russian dossier FISA
abuse fraud literally purposely
misleading committing a fraud on a court
on multiple occasions using spies and
informants to deep state efforts to
undermine a president elected by you the
American people after they first tried
to steal an election tonight we shine a
spotlight on all of this and tonight
we're taking it apart piece by piece
because we are only days away from the
release now that the classification has
occurred of major documents that will
all expose the real election scandal the
real efforts to spy on the Trump
campaign FISA applications 302s gang of
eight Intel material exculpatory
material as I said an avalanche is
coming B cascading down with truth for
the American people there's no stopping
it now it's not a matter of if it is
when this all becomes public
so the gig is up for the
Trump media mob their Democratic allies
they've been pushing lie after lie after
lie for two and a half years and also
remember this which is really important
because how this all started
a phony investigation it all started
because Hillary Clinton should win a
hundred million to zero and by the way
if you voted for Donald Trump
you're a smelly Walmart voter I like
Walmart and by the way you're an
irredeemable deplorable that clings to
your god your guns your Bible religion
that's what the Democratic Party thinks
of us a massive amount of top-secret
classified material was found on her
unsecured private server in a
mom-and-pop bathroom closet called and
managed by Platte River networks yes
that's a crime 18 USC 793 she committed
real felonies and she had a clear intent
when she destroyed the evidence by
deleting 33,000 emails bleach bid on the
hard drive busting up devices with
hammers and removing SIM cards where's
all the democratic and media's theory
about real obstruction with a real crime
real intention oh that's right one
standard for the Clintons one standard
for Democrats and one for everybody else
look at your screen look at what the
violation is 18 USC 793 we've talked
often about it so why was Hillary
Clinton cleared why did they rig that
investigation why did call me and struck
well you know why did they change in May
of 2016 before they ever interviewed
Hillary oh the other people involved why
did they change them from the legal
standard of gross negligence to extreme
carelessness there was clear
overwhelming incontrovertible evidence
that this secret classified information
was mishandled and put on a server which
made it illegal multiple felonies clear
incontrovertible evidence she destroyed
the 33,000 subpoenaed emails and did all
the things to eliminate all the evidence
and remember the struck and page text
about Trump voters members smelly
Walmart people Hillary remember win is
100 million zero well they
the lead investigators in this case and
then immediately turned on Donald Trump
after struggle was the one that
interviewed Clinton and actually allowed
two other people in the room at the same
time that never happens you know he was
writing Hillary's exoneration in May
they did an interview hurt until July
2nd of 2016 Comey cleared her on July
5th 2016 but not before Cheryl Mills was
granted immunity not before the infamous
tarmac meeting with Bill Clinton and the
Attorney General at the time Loretta
Lynch so what did Lynch know when did
she know it because struck and Paige
also say that Oh Loretta Lynch rigged
Hillary's investigation horribly flawed
and injustice and if we want to save
this great Democratic Republic ation of
our laws and we must be ever so village
vigilant to be a constitutional republic
after Clinton lost then the insurance
policy kicked in all roads lead back to
the dirty Russian dossier bought and
paid for by Hillary Clinton the DNC with
funneled money through a law firm into a
knot research firm and then yeah a guy a
foreign national that put these Russian
lines together and then those Russian
lies bulk of information as the Nunez
memo the Grassley gram memo says to
literally spy not only on Carter page
but a backdoor to spy on all things
campaign Trump all things transition
team Trump all things President Trump
put together by Christopher Steele who
doesn't even stand by his own work in an
interrogatory in Great Britain said I
have no idea of any of this is true he
was also being paid by fusion GPS but
really paid by Hillary and remember DOJ
official Bruce or at the time the fourth
highest ranking member of the DOJ he was
warning in August of 2016
Steele hated Trump Hillary paid for it
and none of it's verified and now even
the New York Times of course two years
later than this show says the dossier
was likely Russian disinformation from
the very beginning and the State
Department official John Solomon broke
the
that Kathleen Cadillac was also sounding
the alarm
after meeting with Steel days 1012 days
before the first FISA application was
signed by Jim Comey night after night we
have literally been unpeeling the layers
of this onion and ripping the masks off
all of this corruption trying to get to
the truth to expose what has happened
here this was an attempt to literally
fix a presidential election and destroy
a duly elected president there is a deep
state and now their day of reckoning has
come and by the way the time for
accountability is now